I'm kind of with you with a lot of stuff
and I'll be honest with you I'm not
fully on board with flatterer
that's a hard one it was all I was
violently opposed to it I was mad at
people that would bring it up and that's
normal every everybody that's in to
flatter it was very hard for them to get
into it in a minute it took like a year
and a half for them doing it well first
it was black dudes basically I feel like
that right now I was violently opposed
to it but the one thing about flattered
at the punch and flatter on YouTube
you're gonna get all the debunker bunker
why is there so many people working
against it it's crazy it's a say it's
it's they're doing the exact same thing
to flattered that they do to 9/11 JFK
iran-contra they got people producing
debunking video yeah why are you doing
that if it says that it says I think you
should ask yourself why is there a
debate about it how is there a debate
still and this time with the internet
why are people and people are there's so
many people that are afraid to admit
that they're looking in the flat earth
because the amount of ridicule you get
yeah I mean I was I was quiet about it
but I was against it I was trying to you
know people kept coming up sad you have
you have you looked in the flatterer
than like [ __ ] yeah you're crazy it's
like a couple years ago yeah [ __ ] Joe I
was on Joe's podcast and he would bring
them girls dude people are so dumb
there's some people out there still
believe the earth is flat I'm like what
the [ __ ]
really there's people like that and this
was just a few years ago man now here in
now you're yeah and then I kept trying
to debunk it I would get in arguments
with people and that's the typical story
everyone's trying to debunk it then the
one thing that made me realize something
was wrong as I always believed that the
moon the moon landings were faked and
that's what I thought NASA was I thought
NASA was in charge of the moon missions
I didn't think they were in charge of
all space information I thought there
was all these scientists everywhere and
they're there figuring out you know [ __ ]
about the universe and once I once I
once liked and I was looking into it and
I realized oh should all these pictures
of Earth from space they're all CGI
composites and NASA admits it they got
you know what we take the images and all
they we take this information strips and
then we get an artist to put together
like wait a minute you guys aren't even
getting real pictures of the [ __ ]
earth from space I go ahead the picture
where's the bootlegs yeah where's them
[ __ ] space bootlegs and you get that
you get
earth on your iPhone that's the default
the default picture I got I had looked
at Earth everyday on my iPhone I see
that guy how you gonna tell me that
hurts flat I seen so the guy said goat
cuz I got I got a math a master's in
engineering look into it and so I did
and I realize damn then I started
tracing these pictures back to NASA then
I realized wait a min asseh NASA is
controlling all our space information I
go NASA does that I thought they just
did the moon in the Space Shuttle yeah
an otter do they've been around for 60
years they've been to the moon allegedly
four times now six times
yes six times and they destroyed all the
technology come on man dude that's the
worst if that was a business you'd be
like yeah that you know what they had to
say they destroyed it what are they
gonna say what else they're gonna say I
love people they destroyed all the video
the raw video footage the raw audio
footage all the telemetry data which
tracked where they were in space oh
that's gone because there's no way that
they could even leave that for us to
really look at yeah and I look I think
the biggest thing is to think and try
and be brave in your thoughts because
you know I mean I grew up you know with
you know a lot of Christian influence
around me and stuff and at first it was
scary for me to start thinking about
other things because I didn't want to
because it was just in my makeup that
made me feel like oh it was a little bit
wrong but now man I love to think about
it you know if I'm not thinking about it
then what I'm just wasting a lot of my
time here I'm just going to accept
everything for like complete face value
without questioning it just seems
ridiculous to me uh people are all on
board with putting up memes that say
question authority you know we all know
ones like say no don't question
authority nobody says that nobody would
ever say don't question it though some
people are I mean I go back to the
middle monkeys man like uh you know I I
believe that we're closely related to
and that we have a lot of the same stuff
but I've never been to the zoo and been
like you know [ __ ] you know I miss the
old neighborhood like I don't have any
feeling like that in my body you know
like if I see the monkeys at the zoo I'm
not like oh that's the old gang you know
I'm gonna feel any [ __ ] connection
when you break down like evolution and
Darwin and Isaac Newton and although
their Freemason Jesuits man all the
major astronomers Jesuit Jesuit it's all
part of the plan
they control like the Vatican has the
most powerful telescope
you know what it's name is Lucifer Jesus
the vatican's it's a dark art there
telescope had no is named Lucifer it's
almost like they're [ __ ] with us they
are man how you gonna call Lucifer man
I'm sane I thought you guys hated that
much what the [ __ ] going on over you
call the Lucifer and then we don't see
anything that they're saying come you
don't show us what you're looking at
yeah a couple Vatican I'm you know shows
an algorithm Vatican JP I'll never
forget done me and Joe and we [ __ ]
balls deep into space and [ __ ] back like
in 2001 we're watching a documentary on
the VLT telescope and that stands for a
very large telescope VLT it was a
documentary about it like in 2001 and
they were building it somewhere in South
America where it's you know 360 days
it's clear or they happen it's a the
perfect place for a gigantic the most
powerful telescope ever the documentary
was about building it they weren't it
wasn't done yet it was three giant
mirrors that were gonna be linked
together through software through
computer software and they said by 2005
they're gonna be able to take shot
they're gonna be able to take shots of
the moon like right on the ground like
we're gonna be able to see the and
nothing yeah and where is it since 2005
and it's 2018 there's no shot where's
the shot as a nod am especially if it's
a rag on the moon let's see the flash
yeah let's see that they're not showing
[ __ ] on the moon things shall have
nothing up well they also said to this
is this is something to heard that
whenever they took off that the that the
shuttle knocked the flag down and that's
why you can't see it that's why what a
great excuse oh yeah that's the look at
the moon look at the moon like the
conspiracy theory is that the moonlight
the moon is its own luminary its it's
not a ball of sand it's actually it's
like a light like a nighttime Sun it's a
light and the crazy the craziest thing
about the moon and and and before I got
into flatter the crate I could never
wrap my brain around how if the moon is
orbiting around us and it's a ball we
why do we always see the exact
same side and they say it's a
synchronous orbit he goes it's like
holding hands with someone in training
but still even if it's a synchronous
orbit the after a while it would move a
little bit eventually we would see the
[ __ ] back of it but we never see the
back year after year decade after decade
millennia after millennia it's the same
side of the Moon it's the same face it
doesn't even move like a little a little
bit you would think yeah I mean listen I
mean even just some of the stuff it's
like first of all Pluto that's what they
talking about a ton growing up and then
suddenly fifteen years ago
Oh Pluto doesn't exist remember that
Pluto wasn't [ __ ] real what the [ __ ]
they're saying there's a bunch of Pluto
so they can't count Pluto as a planet
yeah they can't find out they'd have to
count that it's its crane and then the
speed thing it's like oh we're spinning
at this and we're going this the numbers
almost sound like something a kid would
say yeah you know little brother sixty
million seven hundred Julianne yeah
thirty-seven about the International
Space Station supposedly is going 17,000
miles an hour you guys are supposed you
guys dock on that [ __ ] four
times a year you guys said a cargo ship
yeah with with app scientists
international scientists that you're
gonna yeah four times a year you're not
you're docking on something that's going
17,000 miles an hour yet there's no
footage of it there's no footage and the
one thing that will prove that the earth
is round the one thing it's really easy
people say man you need to start a going
what does it prove it's really easy
people always come up with this crazy
[ __ ] I start a GoFundMe go to the edge
raise this money go to the edge fly get
on a rocket fly it see for yourself you
wouldn't even believe it if you saw her
yourself you don't have to spend all you
have to spend is $17.99 $17 go to Best
Buy hmm
buy a [ __ ] go poke can't go pro
camera put it on one of those goddamn
scientists that you [ __ ] that go four
times a year put it on one of those
scientists I want an uncut video of them
going into the rocket going even if it
takes 17 hours I'll watch the whole
thing taking off uncut docking onto the
International Space Station getting off
and then looking back at Earth if you
could do that in one shot I will shut
the [ __ ] up
to bring to the edge with a to go to
Best Buy $17.99 we don't need a GoFundMe
now shut the [ __ ] up with that alright
so I this actually brings up to what I
wanted to ask you and what's preventing
me from going all on board with Flat
Earth is that you know when you go on
YouTube you know there's a lot of people
with too much time and money on their
hands and they're buying weather the
boiler balloons attaching GoPro cameras
to it or just any cameras and launching
it up into space and if you watch that
footage I watch it yeah okay
there's no curvature well no but um
because some of them don't go high
enough this is what I know exactly yeah
this most GoPro cameras have fisheye
yeah so you could tell that really quick
so a lot of people go look I could see
the curvature cos dude that is obviously
fisheye lens so the ones that go up
without the fisheye lens they go up
they've been balloons a bunch of them go
up you could watch it on YouTube the
ones that don't ask fisheye lens they go
up a hundred and ten thousand feet a
hundred and ten thousand feet a hundred
and twenty one thousand feet they go up
there and there's zero curb and it was
brought to Neil deGrasse Tyson's
attention they asked him this he says
it's on video - they said Neil because
Neil is one of their puppets he's yeah I
don't trust him yeah exactly
totally he's one he's a part of the club
they go we need a scientist who's a good
talker and he's funny and charismatic
they got he's an actor that guy's an
actor she's like Bill Nye the Science
Guy
those are actors they're trying to push
the science agenda but anyways so when I
asked Neil Neil deGrasse Tyson they go
how how come with these amateur balloons
we're not seeing any curvature at 120
1000 feet and Neil deGrasse Tyson said
that's not high enough you need to go
weigh hard core the earth is so big
that's what he said they died but then
they got all these people all these
people say dude look I'll get on a plane
and look out a window you could see the
curb but dude that's 35,000 feet and it
if Neil deGrasse Tyson is saying at 121
thousand feet
you're still not high enough and that's
the max for these balloons they can't
get any higher if he's saying you need
to go higher to see the curb then how
the [ __ ] people saying they see it at
35,000 miles on a plane it doesn't make
any sense fix that does not make any
sense if anybody can explain that Neil
deGrasse Tyson you're old boy you're all
boy said that [ __ ] yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying even like a patsy you create
one they're gonna mess up every now and
then they're not gonna get it alright
yeah what I'm saying there know what you
know why the right there and and I'm Joe
Rogan
me and him were having her Flat Earth
discussion and battles and debates and I
say you know what we could handle this
you know this is handless one for once
in a frock why don't we get Eric do bang
he's the best flattered there's a lot of
shields yeah are you talking about a
money more Eric Dubay versus Neil
deGrasse Tyson on JRE oh well that would
be that would destroy the Internet right
and Joe was all for just that we could
[ __ ] make that happen and he eat
contacts in the old deGrasse Tyson goes
dude I contracted Neil we're gonna do it
I contact Eric Tobago it's [ __ ]
happening and right when right when Joe
Rogan even put it on a schedule he said
like for February he's talked about it
on his Podesta he's talked about her on
his podcast in this and then right when
it was announced Eric Dubay his YouTube
channel gets deleted mm-hmm it gets
deleted I'm not crazy but he still wants
to do it so so now tears above our Eric
Dubay if you go to his YouTube channel
and he's made a video going Joe when's
this gonna happen look you put it on
your schedule you talked about it on
your podcast when's it gonna hit on neil
degrasse Joe wants to make it happen the
problem is Neil deGrasse Tyson he don't
want none Eric Dubay he could no no
there's no way he's gonna debate yes for
it just that that little demonstration
of we right how we should see he does
want to answer that every six months
there should be a different set of stars
completely different but they can't
answer that one they can't answer that
one for people to think that's my
biggest thing man yeah people think
we're shooting through the universe at a
million miles an hour and spinning in a
circle and going and going and the whole
thing without gravity that heliocentric
model that mainstream model falls apart
gravity is what holds everything
together I think about this if people
asked like they say well a children will
ask this well if the earth is spinning
at a thousand miles an hour why aren't
the oceans being flinged off and the
answer is gravity is holding gravity's
at wild yeah taffy yeah
gravity is holding oceans to it right
now gravity is holding skyscrapers
otherwise skyscrapers would fling off
oceans would fling yeah right if this
force is so strong it's so strong that
it's holding oceans to it how come it
doesn't [ __ ] with a helium balloon is a
helium balloon is that anti-gravity yes
no what it isn't the other conspiracy
theory with gravity is that and I didn't
make this up
gravity has never been proven it's never
been measured Isaac Newton came up with
it and it it doesn't hold water
literally if if if the reason why a
helium balloon Rises and doesn't get
stuck to the ground is because helium is
less dense than the air or anything is
just our weight it's not grab density
and buoyancy think about it you throw a
rock into the ocean it sinks to the
ground you throw a tennis ball into the
ocean it just floats because the air
inside that tennis ball is less dense
than the water anything that's less
dense goes up anything that's more dense
than the medium that holds it sinks
there's a density hold a density think
how come how come if you if thing about
this what creates density the force on
it right the gravity what was the
question
like what creates like dense he like
what makes one thing dense and one what
I'm saying is I'm no scientist I don't
know but I'm just as a ready just human
man yeah I'm thinking why you would
think like a 250-pound man say you know
Ray Lewis is yeah would it be easier for
him to hold a baby stuck to the ground
or another 250-pound man baby yes that's
common sense right yeah he's got all
this force against a baby
gravity is has the force to hold oceans
stuck to it yet it can't hold a
butterfly stuck to the butterfly we
should be stuck to the [ __ ] ground
like a like some kind of magnet but yeah
we're not but oceans are being held and
if gravity is holding oceans to it then
there must be gravity must be fighting
the inertia of that 1000 mile an hour
spin right so there's a battle
when the inertia flinging the water off
and the gravity holding it together you
would think where was it where we are a
little more maybe a splash where is
there evidence of this this battle at
all between the inertia and the gravity
there is no battle this should it should
be like the ocean should be like leaning
to one side kind of all the time you
know kind of doable
yeah and and water you can't find it if
we were truly a ball with a
circumference of 25,000 miles an hour or
25,000 miles sorry you got to lead us
though man yeah but but if if it's true
then the the ball should Bend at 6,000
feet per every hundred miles so we
should be able to measure the curve of
oceans every hundred miles there should
be six six thousand feet of curvature
yet you could go on YouTube and hear
there's a there's a video on a an 8 a US
Navy quartermaster he's a quartermaster
he works on like [ __ ] battleships and
he says you on YouTube just YouTube US
naval quartermaster and he explains
because there's no way there could be
six thousand feet of curvature at a
hundred miles because they're targeting
and imaging ships at a hundred miles it
would be impossible if there was a 6,000
feet curve right there was no there
would be no way they could target it
there should be six thousand feet of
curvature at 100 miles so yeah that is
it yeah and then if if the world is a
ball with at with the circumference of
25,000 miles then every hundred miles or
should be six thousand feet of dip and
there is it and and also when you're on
a plane
you should be every five minutes you
should be dipping dip in the nose dip in
the nose to spy on it otherwise you just
go right into space yeah but they never
dip their nose they just they're just
hovering over a plane yeah at there
they're just keeping there's so many
there's if the dark goes on forever yeah
and the crazy thing is there's websites
out there that like if you heard of the
Flat Earth Society the Flat Earth
Society is where like Obama is directing
everybody he brings that up because this
is not a meeting of the Flat Earth
so we sending everybody to the flatter
society which is a bunk website yeah
nobody that's a true flat earther has
gone through they bypass the flatter
society because if you're a versa if
yeah exactly if your first introduction
to the flat earth like you're curious
like everyone keeps talking about the
flattery and then you hear about flatter
society because they they pump that up
they want to send you there you go and
you you punch in Flat Earth on Google if
you punch in Flat Earth on Google right
now the first thing's gonna come up is
the Flat Earth Wikipedia which is all
controlled and it looks ridiculous
and then the Flat Earth Society is right
there it's gonna direct flatter Society
on the first page all over the place so
if you go to flatter society first
you're never gonna be flat yeah because
right they're gonna they want to send
you first and so you might as well think
for yourself you cannot take you that
you don't see that oh yeah if you got to
be wild if you're curious about Flat
Earth there's a lot of people out there
there's a lot of great information the
YouTube channel beyond the imaginary
curve great [ __ ] Eric Dubay is YouTube
channel great [ __ ] those links in yeah
the great great [ __ ] we want to get a
question or two real quick any about
some of our listeners I appreciate it
man I appreciate the information I
appreciate you having an open mind man
that's yeah well good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one